[Music]
it's just wonderful to see how
everybody's really excited just like we
are Berlin science week is one of our
favorite events throughout the year it
promotes science in the best possible
way and the event is growing more and
more
at the Berlin science week people from
all over the world researchers come and
discuss the great challenges we have in
the world we need to learn to listen to
what Society wants and how to respond to
their needs Ambitions and drivers
everyone in this world already knows
that sustainability is necessary that we
need to protect the environment that we
need to protect our planet if we want
want to go to a sustainable Society I
think it is very important that we try
to work together we won't be able to
solve the challenges of tomorrow or of
today even if we're just doing it
isolated so we really need each other
and therefore we need science
Communications so many people with so
many different backgrounds come here we
had so many International people look at
our robot exhibition and it's just a
perfect venue to share our research with
the
public science Outreach is becoming more
and more necessary
um climate change even now some people
still think that it's it's uh not real
so it's really important to uh ramp up
the scientific temperament in people we
had lots of people asking very specific
questions so the audience was very
[Music]
educated
many of the people that don't work in
science don't have really an easy access
for science so it's a it's a really nice
way from scientists to show the people
what they do but you you pick up some
ideas to get into deeper after if you
want
[Music]
to there's no doubt that science is the
bridge between peoples we will be back
next year and we're very much looking
forward to
that why not I mean bringing art science
and an international understanding
together we cannot underestimate how art
uh brings people
[Music]
together
and today we have the art fair I think
it's very important to combine Art and
Science to open each other's minds to
create new ways of understanding and we
all gather here in order to show how do
we uh approach science and art uh from a
very personal
[Music]
perspective
public Outreach is most important we
have more than 80 speakers from science
and about 500 guests to
[Music]
listen so I think it's important to find
ways to translate this abstract science
in in different forms and art has so
many tools and options to do that it's
about giving an impression of what is
actually going on at University in the
lab and we try to translate this to
sound so this performance it's inspired
by the photonics of the diatoms and we
are here trying to upscale their Nano
structures to a visible scale in ice
sculptures the humans built these
structures to build quantum computers
and we found that these structures also
exist in nature the most surprising
thing is that we are not able even on
such a large scale to match the beauty
of the natural
structure there are analogies between
Art and Science besides you know the
fact that we can transform our waves in
sounds The Sounds is a way to opening
maybe new Windows into the
[Music]
universe at this point we could get a
bit philosophical but unfortunately I
studied biochemistry and now so I just
want to teach you a bit how we convert
energy in our body during
raving
[Music]
you can't avoid it anymore if you're
interested in science if you're doing
science you have to be
[Music]
there
he